[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a este programa
semanal canadá en las américas café
también conocido como el castor
cibernético de este viernes 6 de marzo
en vivo y en directo por en nuestro
sitio internet en facebook live
youtube y en nuestra aplicación en
bienvenidos entonces acá a esta nueva
emisión y como se han dado cuenta me
acompañan en estudio
leonora chapman y luis laborda
bienvenida
de vacaciones es ahora porque tenía en
mente que le decía que falta uno y él
leonardo que está de vacaciones
bienvenido muchísimas gracias a todos y
también tenemos como ya se han dado
cuenta del otro lado de la mesa una
invitada se trata de él y pero ella es
encargada de programas en américa latina
para el organismo de cooperación
internacional oxfam québec bienvenida a
jolie gracias por invitarme y jolie nos
va a hablar en el marco digamos del día
internacional de la mujer
jolie nos va a hablar de este programa
en bolivia que busca entre otras cosas
fortalecer en los derechos de las
mujeres en bolivia
pero primero y antes que todo un cordial
saludo saludo a todos ustedes allá del
otro lado del micrófono y de la cámara y
bueno pues esperamos que este programa
sea de su agrado lo preparamos de todas
formas todas las semanas con mucho
cariño
sabemos que que no es un encuentro
semanal es como si fuéramos a visitar
una novia o un novio está muy bien
preparado de extranjeras
[Música]
un buen amigo un buen amigo una buena
vida entonces con ese esmero lo
preparamos para ustedes este programa y
pero antes de entrar de lleno en este
canal en las américas café yo creo que
hay temas que debemos resaltar en
particular porque han llamado a una
estrategia ni porque lo venimos tratando
y louis en tu caso es el coronavirus o
sea en no nos podemos escapar de el
coronavirus bueno hasta el momento nadie
ya quedó exento del coronavirus las
regiones que hasta la semana pasada no
habían resultado contagiadas ahora sí
detectado y reportado casos es una
enfermedad que mueve a debate nosotros
lo hablamos todos los días entre
nosotros están quienes consideran que la
situación es más que grave estamos
quienes consideramos que la situación es
delicada pero no grave no urgente y eso
a partir del hecho de que la cifra de
gente contagiada y el caso específico de
muertos que se han producido hasta el
momento siguen siendo relativamente bajo
si uno toma en cuenta la población
mundial entonces cuando se habla y son
datos recientes los tome antes de venir
para el estudio de 100 mil 686 contagios
a nivel mundial comparados con los 7000
o 7.500 millones de habitantes que tiene
el planeta hay que decir que es una
cifra
muy muy baja y si la comparamos
inclusive con la influenza común ha
producido hasta el momento mucho menos
contagios y mucho menos muertes que esa
otra enfermedad es la gripe normal que
le da a uno todos los índices
el que aquí afecta a mucha gente y que
inclusive a quien que ve cada año
produce un número importante de muertos
lo que produce urgencia lo que produce
preocupación lo que produce inquietud en
todo caso es el hecho de que como esta
enfermedad se va desperdigando por el
planeta y es cierto que hoy por hoy ya
no queda ningún continente exento esta
semana particularmente esta semana ha
declarado casos américa latina que era
hasta ahora la única región que
permanece indemne al contagio del
coronavirus junto con africano bueno
áfrica se había tenido algún caso de
hecho había habido uno en egipto por
ejemplo pero es cierto que áfrica es el
segundo continente que menos casos
registró hasta el momento y en el caso
específico de américa del norte hay
hasta el momento confirmados 13 casos en
ecuador
en brasil y en chile hay cuatro en cada
uno argentina tiene dos y en las últimas
horas esta misma mañana ha confirmado su
primer caso perú que hasta hoy estaba
exento del contagio de la enfermedad
luego hay también algunos casos en la
región del caribe principalmente en
costa rica que hay un caso y el
república dominicana donde hay también
otro contagio del número de muertos
hasta el momento sigue siendo
extremadamente bajo se multiplicó en los
últimos días en eeuu pero en la mayoría
de los casos corresponden a gente mayor
a gente anciana que estaba internada en
un mismo hogar de ancianos y que se
contrajo la enfermedad y al tener
condiciones médicas pre-existentes bueno
se agravaron con el coronavirus y eso
desembocó lamentablemente en el deceso
de estas personas pero la cifra global
de muertos llega hasta el momento a tres
mil 411 personas y si uno de los
gráficos que aparecen en las distintas
plataformas que refrescan minutos
minutos de información sobre el
coronavirus hay una meseta tanto en el
número de contagios como de muertes
y la línea que va creciendo rápidamente
es la línea de casos recuperado de gente
que se ha curado de la enfermedad así
que más allá de la urgencia o del temor
mejor dicho que produce el hecho de que
la enfermedad se esté desperdiciando
geográficamente en cuanto a la cantidad
de gente afectada las cifras los números
en los últimos días no ha no ha variado
significativamente es cierto que hay un
crecimiento muy importante sobre todo en
irán donde los casos se están
multiplicando una ahora en italia es
bueno que esos son creo los dos países
más golpeados creo el país más golpeado
fuera de china es corea del sur
que tiene seis mil casos y escuché
también que hay
hubo se detectó un perro con el
coronavirus y en ese caso se preguntaban
si hay que también aislarlo en
cuarentena o hasta el momento no hay ni
siquiera una confirmación de que los
animales puedan transmitir el mando así
que realmente debe haber un
pronunciamiento al respecto pero lo
cierto es que hay distintas medidas que
se han tomado en distintos países en la
mayor en los países afectados por
supuesto canadá son los países cuenta
con la mejor infraestructura y controles
para hacer frente al mal el ministro el
primer ministro de canadá sustituido ha
dicho en las últimas horas que por el
momento no se analiza cerrar las
fronteras del país y ha habido una
controversia días pasados por dichos de
la ministra de salud partidos sobre la
advertencia de que la situación no era
grave el lunes último para 48 horas
después llamar a la población a copiar
medicamentos y alimentos y eso produjo
un cierto el movimiento de pánico a 60 y
de preocupación pero además una
sensación de extrañeza
por el hecho de verse pronunciado en un
sentido el lunes horas después
contradecirse lo cierto es que hasta
ahora la enfermedad en canadá no
presenta
características que puedan mover a una
preocupación mayor que de tener ciertas
previsiones
yo quería solamente agregar que eeuu
está aplicando una medida restrictiva
con canadienses que quieren ingresar por
la frontera que estuvieron en países
como por ejemplo irán o italia los están
frenando en la frontera y ya se hablaba
de unos 100 canadienses a los cuales se
le negó la entrada bueno tomando en
cuenta lo que decíamos reciente que los
casos crecen poco pero la expansión
geográfica es la que más se ha aumentado
en las últimas horas una medida que
tienda a controlado los desplazamientos
parece ser la más no menos seguro
muy bien y vamos a encadenar contigo
leonora el mes de marzo es el mes de la
mujer y el 8 de marzo se celebra en
particular el día internacional de la
mujer y hubo una noticia que me pareció
importante
y es que el 90 por ciento de la
población mundial
tiene prejuicios contra las mujeres
claro que esto ya incluimos a las
mujeres también obviamente y ese es el
problema es decir me sorprendió la
noticia cuando vi el título y dije debe
ser una broma aunque el día de los
inocentes no era hoy entonces empecé a
investigar y es una informe una
investigación de naciones unidas mujer y
que llevaron a cabo en 75 países del
mundo que representan esos 75 países el
80 por ciento de la población mundial de
ese 80 por ciento de la población
mundial un 90 por ciento tiene seis
problemas de sesgo de prejuicio contra
las mujeres en términos de normas
sociales de género sobre todo es decir
son como son como normas sociales
establecidas por la sociedad que
establece reglas para comportamientos de
los sexos
por ejemplo para dar para que se
entienda bien de qué estamos hablando
una mujer se dice que una mujer
lava bien los platos pero la mujer no
necesariamente lava los platos mejor que
los hombres sin embargo se espera que
ella la de los platos en la casa estamos
hablando de diferencia
[Risas]
ahora es sorprendente porque como
dijiste en ese es el 90% de entonces hay
una gran mayoría de mujeres que también
tienen ese tipo de sexo de sexo verdad
de sesgo de prejuicio para aceptar las
normas sociales de género hay unas
cifras que tiene que lanzó de que obtuvo
naciones unidas por ejemplo datos
socioeconómicos que dice que la mitad de
hombres y mujeres del mundo consideran
que los hombres son mejores líderes
políticos que las mujeres eso ya lo
escuchamos muchísimas veces también que
un 40 por ciento opina que los
ejecutivos son mejores en términos
empresariales que las mujeres y que
además tienen derecho a ocupar un
trabajo ellos cuando el empleo escasea o
sea que las mujeres mismas piensan que
si hay escasez de trabajo
cuando hay un trabajo en el hombre el
que debe ocuparlo pero lo más triste
digamos es fue descubrir que casi un 30
por ciento de las personas de esta
encuesta creen que está justificado que
un marido le pegue a su esposa eso
todavía en el siglo 21 me pareció un
poco estamos en la época de las cavernas
vamos a la de bolivia después si en los
últimos días se vio un spot publicitario
con la actual presidenta de bolivia
donde ella dice hace una promoción de la
actividad que ha llevado a cabo desde
que tomó el poder y dice que ha puesto
la casa en orden y efectivamente hay un
grupo de personas que ordenan una casa
la mayoría son mujeres y la que más
ordena es ella que es mujer
bueno ya y finalmente para decir
nosotros negativo también en términos
justamente de sesgo en materia de normas
sociales hubo progresos y esto lo dice
naciones unidas en donde se dio el mayor
progreso fue en chile australia eeuu y
los países bajos bueno otra noticia que
me sorprendió a mí hoy fue justamente el
movimiento de harden en el marco de el
día internacional de la mujer es un
banco es un banco cooperativo acta este
movimiento anunció la creación de un
fondo que invertirá en empresas a nivel
mundial en empresas con representación
femenina es un fondo exclusivo que han
creado para invertir en esas empresas y
resaltar de esa forma el trabajo de la
mujer si bien tenemos acá el mensaje de
amigos que nos están escuchando en este
momento desde sao paulo brasil j moura
dice por muchos años fue oyente de radio
canadá internacional por onda corta
por esta nueva plataforma digital
saludos
también está gustavo lucas que está nos
dice su oyente de la ciudad de melo en
uruguay pero esta vez desde buenos aires
argentinas
sigo de vacaciones dicho se está de
vacaciones además y hugo bbc
hugo lópez él dice saludos desde
santiago de chile
el mejor del mío pues yo no tengo los
mensajes aquí bueno pero pasó el mío y
así puedes ver ir viendo los mensajes a
medida que van entrando y vamos a entrar
ya de lleno con nuestra invitada lee
perro que como les decíamos ésta
está trabajando en este programa del
organismo de cooperación internacional
oxfam québec para reducir la violencia
contra la mujer en bolivia entre otras
cosas
es un programa de cinco años creo y eso
es es un gran proyecto que se va a
llamar mujeres de bolivia tus derechos
en el presupuesto entonces un proyecto
bastante ambicioso que se va a realizar
con el apoyo financiero del gobierno de
canadá también y con varias compartes oa
organizaciones asociadas en el país se
va a desarrollar en 7 municipios en el
eje central de bolivia y bueno donde hay
el los índices más importantes de
violencia contra las mujeres bueno estoy
bueno también me mire el estudio esta
semana y bueno que tiene mucho sentido
porque este proyecto justamente quiere
cambiar las normas sociales las
creencias la manera de pensar como ser
hombre y mujeres y entonces yo creo que
estamos justamente tratando de trabajar
sobre
sesgos contra las mujeres y las mujeres
jóvenes y este creo un proyecto que es
transversal nos decía fuera de estudio
fuera de micrófono ahorita que son 32
países los que están implicados bueno el
de bolivia es único pero es muy parecido
a un programa que existe a nivel
internacional también financiado por el
gobierno de canadá que se llama voz y
liderazgo de las mujeres y que de verdad
se va a desarrollar en 30 países del
mundo y bueno en américa latina'
nosotros vamos a implementar dos de esos
en colombia y honduras y cómo evalúan
tuvo la organización
es el estado actual de la mujer en
bolivia de la violencia de la que
estamos hablando es violencia familiar a
500 niveles es un problema de sociedad
un problema bastante importante y
estructural y es un problema no sólo de
las mujeres sino de los hombres también
es un problema de todos y hasta que la
nueva presidenta decidió lanzar este
bueno una alerta nacional en bolivia
sobre el tema de feminicidio
infanticidio no eso es un año un año
para luchar contra esto bueno desde el
inicio del año es decir dos meses ya
tienen 27 mujeres que fueron asesinadas
por feminicidio por ser mujeres no
entonces es un problema bastante fuerte
pero hay otras formas de violencia
también dentro de la de las parejas de
jóvenes que se enamoran pero viven mucha
violencia muchas muchas formas de
control también y eso también queremos
como actuar a este nivel
jóvenes y desde desde su perspectiva
también de jóvenes este feminicidio por
algo se dice ahora de que el lugar más
peligroso para las mujeres son sus
hogares no claro
en general son bueno casi siete mujeres
sobre diez van a experimentar en su vida
en bolivia una situación de violencia
dentro de su relación de pareja y
tomando en cuenta el periodo político
por el cual está pasando
bolivia un periodo muy difícil como en
qué medida a julie puede este gobierno
boliviano si lo podemos eso puede
influir en el proyecto que ustedes están
llevando a cabo es que les puede afectar
está este cambio de autoridades en
bolivia bueno yo diría que hay varias
posibilidades de impacto uno más
positivo es que el tema de la violencia
es un tema que bueno que está
considerado importante por varios varios
corrientes políticos hasta bueno la
presidenta
hasta otros movimientos en la sociedad
entonces el tema como tal se puede es un
momento bastante
oportuno para trabajar este tema y
encontrar
bueno alianza y aliados y grupos que
quieren cómo terminar con este problema
de violencia pero al mismo tiempo hay
una corriente bastante anti derecho
también en bolivia antes anti derecho de
los hijos de las mujeres de la
diversidad que bueno que promueven más
como roles de mujeres y hombres
tradicionales
bueno canales indígenas o no indígenas
tradicionales más bien patriarcal o
machista o más bien a este nivel no
tanto a nivel cultural lo podíamos
entrar en esto pero no tanto no que es
como más bien la problemática de la
violencia que viene con ese sistema
machista también del hombre que quiere
controlar a las mujeres y entonces yo
creo que es este esta perspectiva está
bastante fuerte y es un movimiento
bastante fuerte en bolivia pero en
varias fases en movimiento también
existía de fuertemente digamos en la
época me imagino del gobierno de morales
también porque esto es un problema que
viene de mucho tiempo no es nuevo ahora
yo no sé si con estas nuevas autoridades
hay una una va a haber una apertura como
tal vez existía con el gobierno anterior
para tratar el tema de las mujeres me
refiero también a presupuesto
para las organizaciones de mujeres bueno
es muy temprano para saber cuál va a
estar el impacto real no porque vamos a
entrar en bolivia en un año electoral
bastante importante a nivel nacional y a
nivel local esperamos que vamos a llegar
hasta las elecciones locales al fin del
año no
y bueno es lo que está previsto y
veremos como cómo se organiza el al
nivel político pero claro que vamos a
estar en un contexto menos favorable que
cuando hemos decidido y diseñado el
proyecto y en este contexto vamos a
buscar la manera de verlo según como se
basan tres comandos y sobre todo porque
hay una parte del proyecto también que
es de de buscar en mejorar el diálogo
con las alcaldías y para tener
presupuesto a inversión municipal a
favor de los derechos de las mujeres y
de prevención y atención de la violencia
entonces ese ese tema tal vez va a estar
más fácil en algunas municipios y
ustedes están trabajando
con un nivel gubernamental municipal y
en siete municipios a cuatro grandes el
alto la paz cochabamba y santa cruz y 13
intermedio viacha n cerca del alto y
colcapirhua cerca de cochabamba y
también en pailón cerca de santa cruz
se habla de 29 mil 186 personas que
están involucradas me parece que es
bastante grande sí bueno yo creo que es
muy importante es ambicioso todavía no
no tenemos estos estas personas pero es
la ambición de impactar sobre 30.000
personas más directamente y más a nivel
indirecto y con una población bastante
joven 90 por ciento de jóvenes entonces
es ahí que vamos a tener un impacto que
queremos tener un impacto grande con la
campaña también que se llama actúa que
es una campaña de prevención y de
movilización de los jóvenes frente al
tema de la violencia entre los jóvenes
precisamente usted hablaba recién de
jóvenes y de la campaña de
sensibilización y movilización como es
una campaña de sensibilización de los
jóvenes respecto a problemas de género
bueno tiene un un enfoque de desarrollar
una campaña desde los jóvenes y con los
jóvenes entonces empiezan como haciendo
una investigación
ellos mismos entonces formamos grupos
chiquitos o ya están formados en algunas
ciudades y se van a investigar sobre el
tema de violencia cómo se da este tema
como sé cuál es la problemática es es el
control de los celulares o es acoso de
las de las jóvenes en la escuela u otras
otras formas y desde esos hechos estas
evidencias van a desarrollar temas de
campañas van a desarrollar vídeos lo
pueden ver en el sitio de la campaña
actúa yo creo que vamos a poner la
dirección en durante la emisión entonces
van a desarrollar muchas actividades
para hacer sensibilización pero con los
jóvenes en los colegios en ferias a
nivel de las redes sociales van a
presentar organizar o presentar vídeos
entonces es ahí que que si se se
desarrolla una campaña y también dentro
de los colectivos de jóvenes de los dos
grupos de jóvenes bueno hacen un trabajo
también de reflexión para ellos mismos
entonces entender de construir un poco
la creencia y tratar de construir nuevas
maneras de ser hombres mujeres y tener
relaciones sana digamos no sin violencia
ustedes recién van a implementar el
proyecto estamos empezando hemos dando
cuánto tiempo tienen qué estrategia
tienen de aquí a cuántos años es esos
proyectos
lo vamos a bueno es un proyecto de cinco
años y ya estamos como casi a la piel al
final del primer año de planeación de
organización ya en algunas actividades
están organizando a ese momento mismo
uno
y entonces estamos entrando en una otra
etapa de la campaña justamente un vamos
a relanzar investigaciones vamos a
relanzar grupos de jóvenes es una
campaña que teníamos antes del proyecto
y que se va a replicar y ampliar dentro
del proyecto como tal habla de los
jóvenes llull y sabemos qué
los jóvenes son bien adeptos a las
nuevas tecnologías es dentro de ese
marco de la campaña las nuevas
tecnologías entran en juego súper
importante no entonces tenemos por
ejemplo hemos desarrollado una chiquita
como superheroína para el proyecto vamos
a tener también redes social bueno canal
youtube de la campaña hay vídeos se
ponen en foto hacen cosas muy dinámicas
en las redes sociales y es un unas de la
plataforma o del espacio donde vamos a
actuar bastante no durante esta campaña
no se va a ser también visita del
colegio animación tradicional film en de
manera más presencial pero el vamos a
tener una presencia bastante importante
a nivel de las redes sociales muy bien
acá tenemos entre nuestros oyentes un
mensaje de ana maría matute ar se dice
hola saludos desde blend build quebec
[Risas]
quebec presente hoy acá y desde bogotá
césar rodríguez cherry dice les saludo
esta semana por el cumpleaños de la
radioemisora un saludo a la voz y al
liderazgo de las mujeres en américa
latina bueno estamos bueno y continuamos
acá entonces con otras preguntas para
mostrar sólo a nivel y cambiando un poco
el ángulo de la entrevista simplemente
sé que estás trabajando en otros países
aparte de bolivia siempre en américa
latina y cómo fue que surge este interés
por trabajar en américa latina de dónde
viene bueno hace muchos años que estamos
en américa latina como oxfam québec sí
pero
a mí bueno mg bueno es me enamoré de la
región no sé hace mucho que viajo e hice
mi maestría en parte de mi maestría en
méxico y bueno me encanta la región
había varios problemas en la región al
momento que encontré la región
80 y bueno me puse bueno fue parte de
muchos muy bien movimiento de apoyo de
solidaridad con américa latina desde los
80 y entonces desde allí bueno he tenido
un recorrido de apoyo a la región
durante unos años no estaba en la región
estuve más en áfrica apoyando otras
organizaciones no con otras
organizaciones pero también con knox
amena en áfrica también sí pero hace
mucho que estoy como tratando de apoyar
esos movimientos sociales son proyectos
sociales tengo con mensaje de gustavo
lucas que dice en francés
felicité julie sohn trabajo
gustavo lucas es uno de nuestros oyentes
top fans y en cuya los programas en
francés en inglés ya que español y aquí
está presente en español él dice en otro
orden les comento que hace una hora
estuve en rail
esradio
recorriendo las instalaciones y
conversando con su director con su
director adrián korol gracias a david
grecia por hacer la gestión para hacerlo
posible entonces pues era un mensaje de
gustavo lucas y bueno pues julie te
deseamos mucho éxito en tu trabajo
espero pues que la
que nos visites nuevamente cuando ya
tengan más información sobre los
resultados de lo que está dando esto no
bueno tenemos equipo fantástico en
bolivia los salud porque creo que me van
a escuchar hoy entonces compartes
colectivos de jóvenes de mujeres que se
van a juntar con nosotros con una
energía bastante fuerte y espero que
vamos a lograr tener una sociedad más
inclusiva muy bien tienen alguna última
pregunta para julie y para mí está bien
yo simplemente saber para cuando ustedes
esperan tener resultados de esta
experiencia
si nos queda cuatro años creo que vamos
a tener efectos antes de impacto
entonces esperamos tener efectos en los
presupuestos municipales oa nivel de
cambio de creencia en los años que
vienen pero eso estamos empezando un
trabajo de largo plazo no cambiar la
creencia la cultura es algo largo pero
esperamos lograr algunos impactos dentro
de los cuatros años que vienen no te
invitamos a quedarte con nosotros julie
si te parece bien súper
aquí en nuestro programa vamos tenemos
mensajes represados que nos enviaron
nuestros oyentes con respecto a este
programa de la semana pasada en el
aniversario de radio canadá
internacional yo no siento porque tengo
acá un comentario enviado por william
señor ariza que dice primero
felicitarlos porque de verdad es muy
fácil decir 75 años pero involucrar
sacrificios esfuerzos y mucho trabajo no
tiene precio segundo agradecer por tanta
información entrevistas y comentarios
tan entretenidos llenos de tanta
sabiduría tercero darle también mis
felicitaciones a todo ese bello equipo y
en especial a un gran amigo de infancia
que debe ser el que está al lado mío
quien con mucho sacrificio y trabajo ha
logrado escalar vertiginosamente en un
medio tan competitivo y hermoso -pablo
de corazón mis saludos y un fuerte
abrazo es una misión amigos si vamos en
la misma calle en la calle 48
barranquilla desde chiquititos somos
amigos y bueno muchas gracias
william por ese reconocimiento louis si
yo tengo mensaje que envía antonio a ver
y no da silva dice fer y cumpleaños en
recibir y todo el equipo por esta fecha
tan importante de la emisora canadiense
más de siete décadas transmitiendo su
señal para el mundo por la onda corta y
hace unos años sólo por internet gracias
por existir saludos a todos
antonio a bwin avelino de caruarú
pernambuco brasil yo ya me recuerda no
no nos trate recuerdo yo no estuve en el
programa del 75 aniversario la semana
pasada me hubiera gustado mucho estar
pero lo escuché lo vi lo leí y lo
encontré excelente como programa la
participación de tanto tantos
colaboradores oyentes que participaron
en esto más acá y me estuve acordando
también de otros otras personas que
trabajaron muchísimo muchísimo tiempo el
radio canadá internacional pienso los
corresponsales pablo vos te debes
acordar muy bien de salvador argüello
que era corresponsal nuestro durante
años en ottawa carmen rodríguez en
q ver está en toronto es presentar un
mensaje aquí de él freddy vélez estuvo
sandra estarías sandra farías en toronto
estuvo aquí en montreal mano ahí lo
estuvo
liliana lilian doctor hubo muchísima
gente que pasó por porque trabajó con
nosotros no y que lamentablemente cuando
hubo esos cortes tuvieron que irse no
entonces hay que recordar un poco todos
esos esos colegas que pasaron también
por acá no justamente fred niveles no se
envió un mensaje él dice me une así vice
radio canadá un cordón que es como el
umbilical uno que aunque se cortó tiene
una punta dentro de mí fui parte de ese
equipo maravilloso entre el 2003 y el
2010 y el recuerdo de esa experiencia es
más que bueno un lugar al que llegue por
sugerencia generosa que hiciera mi
colega rufo valencia y en
que tuve la oportunidad de lograr la
mayor expresión profesional en mi
carrera como periodista en estos 20 años
en mi segunda patria
gracias a leonora chapman quien fue con
paciencia mi jefa y editora casi todo el
tiempo y de quien aprendí mucho sobre
todo en la selección de temas y fuentes
y en asuntos de edición gracias al
profesionalismo y la buena onda de gente
con mayor recorrido como el mismo rufo
un periodista muy cuidadoso en la
investigación previa recuerdo con
aprecio la forma sutil de enseñar de paz
de paulo gomes barrios en un cíclope de
ambulante dice y la espontaneidad pasión
y buena vibra de paloma martínez como
olvidar los momentos compartidos en
estudio y fuera de estos con el gran
martín movilla ahora metido más en la
investigación y los documentales en
televisión años después de mi retiro
como corresponsal de toronto me honra
que mis colegas de cuando en cuando me
buscan para que al aire
compartamos espacios de opinión e
informativos igual les sigo pasando con
mucho gusto datos sobre temas y
personajes que ameritan ser motivo de
cobertura o entrevista en radio canadá
internacional en español felicitaciones
a todos los que forman parte actualmente
de la radio ahora en línea un abrazo a
todos y que destape en más de una
botella de vino tinto para celebrar pre
víveres periodistas colombo-canadiense
radicado en toronto muchísimas gracias
freddy fue muy emotivo emocionante es lo
que escribiste
luis laborda más risa con mensajes como
no tengo uno que nos enviaba hugo long y
que dicen mande un saludo en audio pero
aquí lo reafirmo feliz aniversario a mi
querida rci y queremos saber imágenes de
conductores de la época de la onda corta
y una hora leyó mi primer carta allá por
quería salir a los gritos a la calle por
la alegría eso dice hugo long
ah caramba esos recuerdos que me entrego
a uno de edgardo castro brush se dice el
gobierno de canadá debería asumir los
costos de operación de radio canadá
internacional en vez de invertir en
voluntarios para las guerras creadas por
el gobierno de eeuu
independientemente del partido político
que gobierna y acá jose con ojo tamura
dice felicitaciones a todos de rci por
los 75 años una estación muy querida acá
en brasil donde está su sana peña de
puga se pregunta j
moura bueno pues se nota que es uno de
los viejos oyentes nos han estado en
españa o en ecuador se pasea o aquí
claro en montreal pero digo se pasea si
ya está retirada para tu información
jota mora susana está retirada desde
hacía como unos veinte años veinte años
así de que bueno si la vemos por acá
pues te transmitiré lo admitiremos tu
información alejandro paredes pérez de
chile dice feliz aniversario a todo el
equipo de radio canadá
jorge isaac
rangel dice desde venezuela feliz
aniversario radio canadá internacional y
luz marina castellar rico feliz
aniversario radio canadá
entonces si hicimos mensajes por este
aniversario que bien pues sí y bueno
como el tiempo pasa tan rápido acá yo
creo que le vamos a dedicar ahora un
poquito más de tiempo a los temas que
queremos destacar como lo hacemos de
costumbre y como es costumbre aquí en
este castor cibernético todos los
viernes
leonora tú nos dices que la mitad de las
playas van a desaparecer si no cambiamos
nuestros modos de vida
imagínate todos aquí los inviernos tan
duros y los canadienses que se van a las
playas pues si la cosa no cambia como
dice una investigación europea bastante
alarmante una investigación sobre el
cambio climático pues en 30 años
dicen que va a avanzar el mar como 100
metros sobre las playas de arena y esto
debido a la subida del nivel del mar
entonces también dicen que si no se
hacen nada esos 100 metros fácilmente se
van a duplicar en el año
en 100 años o sea en el año 2100 perdón
en 70 en 80 años ahora dentro de ese
informe que es bastante largos a que los
países que serían más perjudicados con
esta subida de las mareas y del mar y
encontramos que en términos de
superficie total sería canadá y
australia están considerados los más
vulnerables dado que se calcula que el
avance del mar llevará a la pérdida de
15.000 kilómetros de costa en ambos
países a lo mejor a lo mejor va a llegar
a bolivia
y reclamando su salida con esto
lo que dicen por ejemplo este informe
europeo
también destaca cuáles son los países de
américa latina que más posibilidades
tienen de que estas aguas también
arrasen en sus playas y está hablando de
chile que dice que va a perder unos
7.000 kilómetros a argentina unos 4.400
kilómetros méxico unos 5.100 entonces
tenemos aquí un experto que es alan
webster que es miembro del centro
universitario de medio ambiente para el
desarrollo sostenible y que además es un
profesor titular en la universidad de
sherbrooke en materia de medio ambiente
y economía el alerta sobre la costa
norte canadiense la code nor
por dos cosas él dice porque el hielo
que protege la costa de las grandes
tempestades invernales se está
derritiendo por un lado y por el otro
suben las aguas y están avanzando sobre
las tierras esa zona de la costa norte
de la costa norte canadiense va a ser
muy afectada que es toda la parte este
de quebec nuevo bronze week no sé hasta
dónde llegará y hay algo que él dice que
es canadá está muy mal acostumbrado en
términos de utilización de la energía de
los fósiles sin petróleo todavía acá
parece que no se puede vivir y dice una
frase muy interesante a mi juicio que si
continúa canadá con el mismo escenario
energético del siglo 20 las
consecuencias en el siglo 21 serán mucho
mayores incluyendo no sólo en términos
medioambientales sino económicos y en lo
que propone es que quebec y canadá vayan
hacia una sociedad descarbonizada y
entonces también dice que hay una
resistencia de canadá hacia eso habla de
la provincia de nueva brunswick
que está luchando por obtener un
oleoducto para producir y transportar
más petróleo sin hablar ya de las arenas
bituminosas en la provincia de alberta
dice que si está en tal mentalidad y
cultura no sé de consumo no se cambia
pues las cosas van a empeorar ahora si
se logra hay 30 años y él dice tenemos
tres pequeños diseños para cambiar eso
si no lo hacemos ahora bueno después no
se podrá parar más es algo que quizá
pueda ayudar en este proceso es la
conversión de los vehículos automóviles
y otros del carburante a la electricidad
porque en ese momento ya se necesitaría
menos por no sé cuál es la cantidad de
petróleo que se necesita para mover
todos los vehículos que circulan en el
planeta pero si esos vehículos fueran
eléctricos me imagino que el consumo
sería muchísimo esta semana anunció una
iniciativa para expandir los beneficios
para la compra de autos eléctricos
quieren la que quiere que contéis
compren y se utiliza
más que todo lo que sean la electricidad
para el transporte no entonces bueno y
lo que decía este informe para terminar
de que está en el sitio web está ahí
está el link el enlace el enlace para ir
a este estudio europeo que si se actúa
rápidamente en estos tres años se puede
revertir esta tendencia de la de la
inundación de las tierras en más de 40
por ciento lo cual es mucho rcn punto o
sea ahí va a encontrar toda esa
información
gracias leonora louis tú nos hablas de
la semana latinoamericana en la
universidad de quebec en montreal señor
sintéticamente porque no queda poco
tiempo el comité universitario por
américa latina de la universidad de
quebec en montreal va a presentar la
semana próxima entre el 9 y el 12 de
marzo
cuarta semana latinoamericana pueblos
autóctonos donde intenta resaltar la
riqueza cultural de américa latina pero
en un sentido amplio y una de las cosas
que quieren hacer que se impone hacer
este grupo de estudiantes es revertir
los estereotipos que tiene mucha gente
aquí en otras partes sobre lo que es la
cultura latinoamericana más allá de los
actos o de los números artísticos
acostumbrados en este tipo de eventos
como la danza el canto etcétera va a
haber algunos que no son tan comunes
como por ejemplo un debate sobre las
lenguas indígenas en américa latina va a
haber dos mujeres de origen zapoteco que
van a relatar su experiencia como
inmigrantes a montreal siendo
latinoamericanas no hispanohablantes
porque se reivindican como hablantes de
otra lengua que no es el español
indígena exótica efectivamente y va a
haber también además grupos de debate
sobre la actualidad los pueblos
indígenas en américa latina una
actividad que lleva a cabo
este comité universitario durante todo
el año no solamente para este evento es
la realización de grupos de debate con
público en general donde se intentan
abordar temas que tienen que ver con la
actualidad cotidiana de américa latina'
y tratar de revertir un poco la visión
errónea que existe en algunos casos
sobre qué significa ser latinoamericano
que significa ser indígena en américa
latina' y cuál es la realidad que el
pueblo latinoamericano en general vive
en estos días también abordan por
supuesto la cuestión de la actualidad
allí en la región y no podía estar
exento en entonces de estos debates lo
que ha ocurrido en los últimos meses en
casi todos los países latinoamericanos
específicamente en el caso de chile la
protesta en la que han participado con
gran número de participantes valga la
redundancia pero con mucha fuerza los
estudiantes y los indígenas y en las
protestas en chile que reiteramos sigue
en auge en estos días hemos dejado
hablar de ello pero siguen día a día hoy
hay más protestas ahora están deteniendo
estuvieron deteniendo deteniendo a
estudiantes de escuelas secundarias sí
bueno los invito a que vayan todos en la
página tener este evento comienza el
lunes dura hasta el jueves y es muy
importante que la gente que pueda ir
asista porque estos estudiantes han
realizado han llevado a cabo la
preparación de estas jornadas con mucho
mucho esfuerzo
si antes quiero agradecer allá del otro
lado de la pecera a los nuestros
técnicos hoy en día es marc andré de
saint pierre luc bleu y el insustituible
pierre útil del único el único entonces
yo por mi parte los invito a escuchar
una entrevista que hice con el
viceministro primero de relaciones
exteriores de cuba quien se encuentra en
este momento llegó el primero de marzo y
termina hoy su gira aquí en canadá y el
vino a visitar canadá en el marco de los
el 75 aniversario de relaciones
ininterrumpidas entre cuba y canadá
y bueno recordar un hemisferio
canadá y méxico fueron los únicos países
del mundo que no se cortaron relaciones
comerciales con cuba entonces el psc
subraya relaciones diplomáticas quiero
decir bueno y eso fue todo por el
momento así de que en las le agradecemos
inmensamente a nuestra invitada julie
pero quien es encargada de programas en
américa en américa latina para el
organismo de cooperación internacional
oxfam québec muchísimas gracias por tu
visita julie gracias por invitarme y acá
luis laborda y mi persona
hacemos su alta fidelidad hasta la pista
y nos vemos la semana próxima
aquí
[Música]